[Musique]
bonsoir nouvelle semaine d'information
locale sur tv 78 bienvenue dans le
journal de la rédaction nous sommes le
lundi 16 novembre voici les titres
depuis la rentrée dernière le mas qui a
été rendue obligatoire à l'école dès 6
ans ce qui fait débat à versailles une
habitante a lancé une pétition contre le
port du masque toute la journée pour les
collégiens et les lycéens quelle
importance mais aussi quelles
conséquences de la mesure pour les plus
jeunes invités de cette édition marie
lebel député des yvelines et le
professeur richard delorme chef chef du
service pédopsychiatrie de l'hôpital
robert debré à paris
faudra-t-il élire à nouveau un maire aux
généreux concours le tribunal
administratif de versailles statuer
aujourd'hui sur le recours déposé pour
faire invalider l'élection en mars
dernier richard de la pierre richard
delpierre l'avait emporté de 76 voix
d'écart sur les digues sortant philippe
brillault et puis des rassemblements ce
dimanche à versailles
saint-germain-en-laye ou encore
rambouillet des milliers de catholiques
réunis pour faire demander pour demander
le retour à la messe le retour de la
messe les célébrations impôt rappelle
sont interdites est depuis le début du
confinement
mais avant de développer ses titres léa
dernières données du coc vie des 19 dans
les yvelines l'épidémie qui est toujours
présente avec une tendance observée la
semaine dernière qui se confirme la
baisse des indicateurs des tests
continuent taux d'incidence ses taux de
positivité toujours en diminution même
si les deux indicateurs restent encore
très élevées une tendance qui ne se
traduit pas encore à l'hôpital où les
chiffres restent en hausse et des lits
de réanimation quasiment occupé à 100 %
en ile-de-france en une semaine cinq
patients supplémentaires ont été placées
en réanimation dans les yvelines
et depuis le 8 novembre soixante trois
hospitalisations supplémentaires ont été
enregistrées dans le département 790
personnes sont décédées du coronavirus
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
dans les hôpitaux heavy noir autour de
cette actualité est d'ailleurs la vague
de cas au sein de la police nationale
des yvelines c'est nos confrères du
parisien à qui ont révélé cette
information ce week-end 31 agents
positif rien qu'au commissariat de
saint-germain-en-laye
sans parler des cas à contacter aimer
les missions des policiers continuent
tout de même les personnes interpellées
sont acheminés à l'eau
deux polices de sartrouville le syndicat
unité sgp donnant la fermeture totale du
commissariat une décontamination
complète du lieu et un dépistage massif
la semaine dernière à 25k positif avait
été révélée également du côté de mantes
la jolie est les policiers des yvelines
bénéficie du renfort de compagnies de
crs pour compenser les effectifs absents
et assurer la sécurité et vous le savez
pour limiter la propagation du virus le
port du masque reste l'une des
principales mesures barrières des
protections qui sont désormais
obligatoires dès 6 ans en classe la
mesure est entrée en vigueur le 2
novembre dernier à versailles une mère
d'élève à contre-courant elle a lancé
une pétition pour la suppression du port
du masque obligatoire pendant huit
heures de cours des collégiens et des
lycéens elle demande notamment que le
port du masque ne soit plus obligatoire
dans la cour de récréation la pétition a
déjà rassemblé plus de 2900 signataires
explications dans cette interview
express avec l'initiatrice de cette
pétition
cette pétition avait pour but en effet
de d'expliquer que peut-être le masque
huit heures par jour pour nos enfants
c'était quand même est disproportionné
par rapport à mon virus et moi j'ai du
mal à comprendre bon protège qui de quoi
comme c'est très confus et que l'on nous
a dit que les enfants n'étaient pas
forcément porteur donc ça veut dire quoi
alors on porte le masque pour se
protéger des autres enfants pour
protéger le professeur mais qui sur une
estrade en loin
[Musique]
d'abord parce que donc c'est en effet un
inconfort donc il faut il faut quand
même gérer ça en plus des apprentissages
vous apprenez mais vous voyez pas votre
les paroles de notre interlocuteur et je
pense aussi qu'il ya un problème de
relation sociale parce que c'est avec
son visage qu'on rencontre l'autre avec
son sourire avec son expression avec ses
émotions enfin et les enfants c'est
vraiment les adolescents surtout c'est
aussi enfin les amitiés l'orage c'est
presque le plus important et c'est
difficile moi je m'étais dit à l'air
libre dans la cour de récré on peut
peut-être avoir ce temps de respiration
oui en effet quand ils sont à distance
les uns des autres
peut-être avoir des temps où la ménage
dans la journée et aussi qu'on sache
jusqu'à quand parce qu'on va pas
s'habituer à vivre est une société
masqué
je nie pas qu'il ya un virus et qu'il
faut faire attention peut-être le
gouvernement ces diplômes à ce que tout
le monde comme ça voilà mes mais il ya
peut-être des aménagements possibles et
une réflexion à faire sur voilà sur nos
enfants parce que c'est la société
demain et on va pas faire une société de
2,2 d'adultes qui sont qui sont anxieux
dépressifs
il faut réfléchir à ça aussi aux
conséquences et il me semble qu'elles
elles peuvent être plus dramatique si
vous voulez que ce qu'on est censé
éviter aujourd'hui pour parler de cette
thématique du port du masque chez les
enfants en deux invités qui sont avec
moi en visio marie lebey bonsoir ça mais
député la république en marge de la 4ème
circonscription des yvelines et le
professeur richard de l'orne bonsoir
bonsoir chef du service pédopsychiatrie
à l'hôpital robert debré à paris merci
d'être avec nous alors la maman à
l'origine de la pétition dont on vient
de parler elle nous dit que faire porter
un masque à des enfants pendant huit
heures par jour c'est disproportionnelle
parle d'un confort pour l'apprentissage
de problèmes aussi alliée aux relations
sociales elles demandent notamment la
possibilité pour l'enfant de pouvoir
retirer ce masque pendant la cour de
récréation marie le bec quand vous
entendez ceux là qui avaient vous envie
de répondre mais j'entends que pour les
enfants c'est effectivement difficile
d'avoir ce port du masque néanmoins et
j'entendais ce que disait madame martin
meunier je crois juste justement la mère
de famille qui a lancé une pétition
le fait de dire il faut qu'on prépare
pas si la génération à venir il faut
avoir le moins de conséquences possibles
mais notre priorité c'était de pouvoir
garantir que les enfants puissent
continuer à aller à l'école que les
écoles puissent rester ouverte et ça
faisait partie notamment des conditions
pour le maintien des écoles ouvertes et
je crois que c'est très important mais
je voudrais peut-être dire à cette mère
de famille qui s'inquiète que nous
sommes très vigilants à l'état de
l'évolution de la situation sanitaire
est que dès que nous pourrons assouplir
un certain nombre de contraintes et
notamment sur les enfants
nous ne nous ferons après les vacances
de la toussaint on a vu une très forte
reprise de l'épidémie et c'est pour ça
que ça nous à être semblait la bonne
solution
en tout cas pour lutter tout en
permettant aux enfants de continuer à
aller à l'école à l'école ou même dans
la société en général ça reste
port du masque l'une des principales
mesures barrières pour pour contrer la
propagation de l'épidémie
oui tout à fait ça fait partie des
gestes-barrières que professeur delorme
en dira plus que moi sur le sujet mais
je crois que on est dans un moment où
l'épidémie est forte et qu il faut qu on
s'astreint à la fois à respecter les
gestes barrière dont le port du masque
fait partie et aussi dans la mesure du
possible à réduire au maximum nos
interactions sociales et c'est le sens
des mesures que nous avons pris sur les
commerces sur les cultes sur la pratique
d'activités physiques par exemple
professeur de langues déjà sur cette
mesure que pensez vous de sa pertinence
je crois que finalement c'est une mesure
qui a déjà été demandés par l'om est
depuis longtemps elle a été demandée au
tout début de la première phase de
confinement et je crois que la décision
avait été de fermer les écoles
je crois que la décision dans ce
deuxième phase elle est complètement
différent on a bien vu que le fermer des
écoles avait vraiment des conséquences
sur le plan de la santé mentale des
enfants des adolescents et donc il
s'agissait pas de de fermer des écoles
de nouveau donc je crois qu'il ya eu un
énorme effort gouvernement en
particulier
adrien attaque a fait un énorme travail
des secrétaires à l'enfance pour essayer
de maintenir des écoles ouvertes
et puis en parallèle les professionnels
de l'enfance aussi se sont beaucoup
engagé pour essayer de maintenir l'école
ouverte donc oui c'est un certain niveau
de coût mais effectivement cette maman
et je comprends tout à fait son discours
comment protéger les enfants mais
d'abord protéger les enfants c c est
mettre les enfants en relation des uns
les autres et pour que les enfants
puissent aller à l'école c'est il ya un
petit prix à payer qui est celle du
masque mais pour garantir un toujours
cette ouverture des écoles elle l'a dit
cette maman qui a lancé la pétition et
craint des conséquences dramatiques et
ce que a votre avis il ya des risques
sur le plan psychologique peut être
davantage de stress pour ses enfants
d'avoir ce masque à l'école pourri c'est
une évidence il ya plus de stress façon
la période n'est pas extraordinaire
jeudi 7 mai le bâti le port du masque la
première phase 2 2
nico vide on sait que 5 % d'augmentation
du chômage c'est 35 à 50 %
d'augmentation des maladies mentales
chez l'enfant
donc imaginez bien que on est dans une
phase particulièrement contraignante
pour les pros de la santé mentale des
ans et vous le disiez chez nos confrères
de télérama dans une interview
l'important c'est aussi d'insister sur
le côté altruiste du port du masque il
faut selon vous aussi le dédramatiser
comment on y parvient
déjà je vais encore une fois déjà en
rappelant que c'est quelque chose
d'altruiste le masque permet surtout
protéger autrui et je crois que ça c'est
quelque chose de très important je vois
les enfants peuvent très bien entendre
cette situation rend plus les enfants
n'ont pas du tout le même regard que
nous sur le sueur sur le port du masque
quelque chose d'assez résilient l'enfant
s'adapte très vite et c'est vrai que
tant en tant qu'adulte on a beaucoup
plus de mal
on a tous 20 ans 30 ou 40 ou 50 voire 80
ans de vie sans masque et donc voilà
c'est une vie différente avec le masque
quand on est adulte on a nos habitudes
c'est plus difficile pour les enfants on
peut partir à l'école ce qui compte
encore une fois c'est de pouvoir
échanger jouer dans la cour et je crois
oui c'est retient il ya un effort l'om
est à demander cet effort
le gouvernement a suivi cette demande de
concession ne suffit qu'à depuis
longtemps demandait est donc encore une
fois je crois qu'il ya un effort de des
politiques mais aussi des professionnels
enfance pour pour maintenir cette vie
sociale pour l'enfer moi je suis
extrêmement surpris
des efforts qui sont faits les enfants
vont encore faire du sport ils vont à la
piscine poste à fins et c'est vraiment
un bel effort une dernière question ô
marie lebel gens profitent de notre
présence pour élargir élargir un petit
peu cette thématique parler aussi de ce
confinement qui a été décrétée déclenché
depuis le 30 octobre en france et
jusqu'au 1er décembre au moins avec une
on l'a vu une première phase de
pédagogie
les forces de l'ordre tandis qu'elle
dirait davantage vers davantage de
sanctions dorénavant en cas de non
respect de la mesure est ce que ce
confinement de votre point de vue de
députés ce qu'il est bien respectée sur
le département des yvelines
oui dans les villes on a des échanges
réguliers vous savez avec le préfet avec
la rs aussi ans
a effectivement des bons retours sur le
respect du confinement dans les yvelines
j'ai aussi fait le tour avec mes élus
locaux pour voir comment étaient vécus
et appréhender la situation est
globalement il faut saluer le respect
des mesures qui sont prises qui est
alors même que ce deuxième confinement
pour certaines personnes ne peut plus
difficile à vivre et donc moi je crois
vraiment que on est dans une phase où il
faut faire un effort ensemble un effort
collectif pour casser cette dynamique
épidémique de deuxième bague on parlait
du port du masque qui était un acte
altruiste je crois aussi que quand on
respecte le les mesures sont prises dans
le cadre du confinement
c'est aussi un acte altruiste vis-à-vis
de nos personnels soignants pour qu'ils
aient moins de pression dans les
hôpitaux et que même s'il ya des malades
qui arrivent en réanimation après six
heures moins importantes sur les
soignants et qu'ils puissent traiter les
personnes en réanimation dans de bonnes
conditions
merci d'avoir été avec nous marie lebey
qui député de la 4e circonscription des
yvelines merci également au professeur
richard delorme chef du service de
pédopsychiatrie à l'hôpital robert debré
c'est à paris merci d'avoir été avec
nous si bon courage
toujours dans l'actualité du coc vide 19
la région déploie en ce moment des
centres de dépistage antigénique à
proximité de 50 gares franciliennes
c'est ouvert à tous et gratuit et les
tests peuvent s'y faire sans rendez-vous
les résultats communiqués en une
vingtaine de minutes et dans les
yvelines
huit garçons concernés ou vont l'être
prochainement versailles chantiers ou
encore celle de saint quentin en
yvelines à montigny le bretonneux que
vous voyez à l'image
le centre est ouvert du lundi au
vendredi de 13h à 19h carte vitale et
numéros de sécurité sociale sont
nécessaires pour accéder aux
prélèvements le site prévoit de réaliser
1500 test par semaine un reportage plus
complet sera à retrouver à 17 semaines
dans nos éditions sur tv 78 les centres
e les centres de dépistage continue donc
de se multiplier dans les yvelines
samedi dernier c'est la ville de la
verrière qui a également ouvert le sien
à la salle du scarabée des tests anti
génie qui sont aussi pratiques et plus
d'une cinquantaine de personnes a pu
déjà y avoir accès
le reportage de mélanie poker de patrick
jacques de dixmude quand c'est positif
ya deux traits qu'apparaissent s'il n'y
a que un prêt au bout d'un quart d'heure
ça veut dire que le test est négatif
isolé au plus vite les cas positifs
identifier les as un automatique à la
verrière on a fait le choix du test
antigénique pratiqué par les infirmières
installé sur la commune
les municipalités ont un rôle à jouer
pour freiner l'épidémie et grâce aux
infirmières libérales du bois de l'étang
on a organisé en un temps record cette
séance de testing avec des tests
antigénique qui permettent d'avoir des
résultats entre 15 et 30 minutes donc
des résultats quasiment immédiatement
pour être assuré pour s'isoler le plus
rapidement possible aux patients ou pour
reprendre le travail
venus pour beaucoup se rassurer les
premiers patients bénéficier des
dépistages gratuits proposés depuis
samedi 14 novembre
je voulais savoir si j'étais positives
et négatives finalement je suis négative
à danser beau de la période qu'on a
actuellement bon on sait pas si on
importe l'heure si on ne l'est pas au
moins comme ça c'est fait qu'on a une
information même si on peut être après
qu'un contact ou pas con je suis
chauffeur de car de tourisme et on ne
sait pas qui monte dans dans le cas
quand on fait les lignes et tout ça donc
j'en ai profité pour pouvoir faire mon
test est la commune met à disposition
une salle au sein du scarabée
l'opération sera répétée chaque samedi
de 9 heures à 13 heures une soixantaine
de tests ont été réalisés pour ce
premier rendez vous l'actualité est
aussi politique avec cette interrogation
l'élection aux municipales valette
va-t-elle être invalidée au chesnay
rocancourt une décision du tribunal
administratif de versailles était
attendu aujourd'hui à l'heure où je vous
parle ce lundi soir à 18h15
la décision se fait encore attendre
rappelez vous le 15 mars dernier à
ryszard delpierre l'avait emporté sur le
maire sortant philippe brillault avec
seulement 76 voix d'écart ce dernier
avait alors déposé un recours pour faire
annuler le scrutin est la raison une
abstention record dû à la crise
sanitaire mais également un sondage à
charge contre lui dont le résultat a été
diffusé quelques jours avant l'élection
finalement ce n'est pas ce motif qui a
été retenue par le tribunal
administratif pour mener cette enquête
mais celui de l'affichage de trois
panneaux accusant philippe brillault
d'être un menteur ainsi qu'une
photographie d'yves eut diffusé sur
facebook montrant une partie de son
patrimoine
aujourd'hui il ya encore toujours alors
je vous parle 18h15 ce lundi soir aucune
nouvelle quant à la décision finale du
tribunal administratif de versailles
nous ne manquerons pas de vous informer
d'ici la fin de cette édition si cette
décision est révélé d'ici là et des
milliers de catholiques réunis dans les
yvelines ce dimanche comme partout en
france des rassemblements ont eu lieu
dans plusieurs villes de france et dans
plusieurs villes du département des
yvelines la motivation de ses fidèles
demandé le retour de la messe patrick
jacques de dixmude et astrid bergère
plus de 1000 personnes à versailles 300
à saint germain en laye à rambouillet
les catholiques yvelinois été mobilisés
ce dimanche devant les lieux de culte
des rassemblements déclarée en
préfecture comme si devant sainte
bernadette à rambouillet et demandent le
retour de la messe très concrètement
qu'on demande c'est que il ya vraiment
ce principe de laïcité qui soit reconnue
avec une véritable séparation entre
l'église et l'état et de laisser
l'église organisé en fait les règles
sanitaires à l'intérieur de ses propres
s'élèvent à sion pour le moment les
églises sont ouvertes et les fidèles
peuvent s'y recueillir individuellement
mais pour les catholiques cela ne suffit
pas la messe doit être célébrée yade aux
dimensions dans la baisse
la première c'est la dimension du
rassemblement voilà le catholicisme est
une religion qu'on ne pratique pas seuls
et pas chez soi ou donc enfin seulement
vous plaît
et puis la deuxième dimension c'est que
la messe est une action qu'il se passe
quelque chose
c'est ce qu'on appelle une biture gines
voilà donc la de cet acte religieux n'a
plus lieu
et ça c'est embêtant la messe est donc
pour les chrétiens essentiel c'est un
moment qui permet aux fidèles de s'unir
autour de la foi quand on est catholique
on croit en jésus et dans la messe mia
j'ai su pour nous voilà pourquoi c'est
important
c'est comme si on parlait de quelqu'un
et qu'on ne voyait jamais ne pas avoir
de metz c'est lundi 16 novembre le
ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
a reçu les représentants des cultes pour
échanger sur les évolutions possibles
des pratiques de la religion
incompatible avec les règles sanitaires
et à l'issue de cette réunion à matignon
a indiqué qu'il n'y aurait pas de
cérémonie religieuse avant la
réouverture des commerces petite
précision par rapport à ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure
concernant l'élection municipale au
chesnay rocancourt qui sera peut-être
invalidé la décision et est toujours
pour l'heure attendu la décision du
tribunal administratif de versailles qui
pourrait rendre une décision selon les
conseils du rapporteur public le
rapporteur public dans cette affaire un
recours qui a été déposé aux chaînés
rocancourt qui avait estimé qu' un motif
pouvait invalider cette élection le
motive c'est le suivant c'est
l'affichage de trois panneaux accusant
fille brio d'être un menteur philippe
brillault c'est le maire sortant du
chéné rocancourt d'être un menteur
ainsi aucune photographie montrant une
partie de son patrimoine qui a été
diffusé sur facebook je vous le rappelle
le 15 mars dernier richard delpierre
l'avait emporté sur le maire sortant
philippe brillault avec seulement 76
voix est des cas ce reportage avec un
nouveau service à destination des
familles dans les communes
d'andrésy dans la commune il n'y a
qu'une seule commune à andrésy une
annexe à du relais d'assistants
maternels principal a ouvert c'était
vendredi à 6 novembre le lieu accompagne
les parents dans la recherche du mode
d'accueil et propose aussi aux enfants
un des temps d'activité collectif mais
cela s'adresse aussi aux assistantes
maternelles directement les précisions
dans ce sujet de justin brasier de célia
agathe son go une nouvelle rame a fait
son apparition à andrésy cette annexe au
relais d'assistants maternels déjà
existant est effective depuis le 6
novembre
elle prend place au complexe sportif
stéphane diagana le bâtiment existait il
y avait un créneau disponible le
matériel existait puisqu'il était
précédemment au gymnase louise weiss
pourquoi ne pas ouvrir ici une annexe ça
ne coûtait pas d'argent le personnel
était déjà présent donc autant faire et
vous voyez c'est ça semble très apprécié
objectif de cette annexe située à quatre
kilomètres du relais principal proposer
un accueil de proximité pour les
assistantes maternelles du quartier qui
traversait la ville à pied avec des
enfants en bas âge fallait prendre la
voiture
bon c'était compliqué surtout quand on a
trois ou quatre enfants
et donc on avait fait cette demande
depuis déjà assez longtemps donc le fait
que ce soit exaucé c'est super pour y
aller c'était pas évident que là c'est
vrai que c'est tout près on peut y aller
à pied et c'est vrai que c'est bien pour
nous à cette opa qui sont de ce côté là
au programme des activités ludiques dans
un esprit de motricité libre grâce à du
matériel mis à disposition avec les
enfants on vient ici peuvent s'amuser
vraiment dans une structure qui est
adapté et ses claques parce qu'ils sont
ils sont plusieurs et puis ils font ce
qu'ils veulent
un créneau horaire est dédié à cette
nouvelle annexe nos vendredi matin de 9
heures à 10 heures vendredi dernier
cette assistante maternelle et une
vingtaine d'enfants ont pu en profiter
le sport et des nouvelles de nos
tribunaux engagé dans le vendée globe
2020 à louis burton poursuit la cour sur
son bateau bureau vallée de il fait
partie des trente deux skippers toujours
en liste l'everest des mers ayant
enregistré hier l'abandon de nicolas
troussel malgré une pénalité de cinq
heures purger pour avoir franchi la
ligne de départ trop tôt et des
réparations à effectuer sur son voilier
louis burton est bien à remonter au
classement
à l'heure où je vous parle donc lundi
soir 16 novembre 18h21 le rambolitains
se trouve au large du cap-vert et pointe
à la septième position au classement son
objectif terminer dans le top 5 est de
ce tour du monde à la voile un vendée
globe qui est toujours dominée pour leur
part le britannique alex thomson sur
hugo boss avant de refermer ce journal
de la culture in sixième édition du
tremplin 1 des voix lancé samedi dernier
une centaine de candidats participent à
ce concours de chant organisé par égard
organisé par une association dans les
yvelines c'est l'association la voix en
scène
immersion dans une première audition
avec patrick jacques de dixmude et
sediag à 200 go mets toi à danser dans
la ronde et laisse moi
voici océane à 18 ans elle vient de
remporter samedi soir son ticket pour la
finale du tremplin des voix dans la
catégorie auteur compositeur interprète
avec sa chanson de l'espoir je reçois le
coup téléphone et jean tremblay en fait
parce que je m'y attendais vraiment pas
je dirais qu'en fait ça ces avantages
d'être sur zoom parce que on est quand
même on a quand même le confort d'être
chez soi même s'il ya toujours le stress
de est ce que mon micro va bien marcher
est ce que l'as connexion va rester
prévu normalement à magny les hameaux et
montigny le bretonneux cette année kobe
19 oblige les auditions ne se font pas
en présentiel
mais en ligne pour cette première
audition 30 participants qui passe par
plusieurs étapes
on a essayé la de reproduire assez
fidèlement ce qui se passe en physique
c'est à dire qu'effectivement ils sont
en plusieurs groupes répartis en
plusieurs groupes et il ya des parts
groupe de passage il ya des groupes qui
vont en coaching
donc ce n est des groupes qui vont en
coaching vocal etc etc
donc c'est exactement le même
fonctionnement la pédagogie et
l'accompagnement sont les maîtres mots
de ce concours de chant
les coaches donne des astuces aux
artistes et leur permettent de se
produire dans un cadre bienveillant
derrière que l' avantage du tremplin des
voix c'est qu'on a et on a beaucoup de
partenaires qui leur offre énormément de
prestations comme des tournages de clips
ou alors tout simplement des producteurs
qui sont en relation avec nous des
directeurs de labels et donc ça leur
ouvre vraiment des portes des autres
auditions france sont prévues en ligne
le 21 et 28 novembre
avec trente participants pour les deux
sessions et les auditions à la réunion
le 12 décembre en physique la finale
composée de quinze à vingt candidats
sera organisée le 30 janvier à magny les
hameaux
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité l'information locale en
direct revient dès demain mardi à 18h
belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]